well good morning folks you're coming
with me for another day in my life in
the hospital i get to show you some cool
aspects of how we've adapted care in the
era of covet 19.
i'm going to shower i promise
thank you i'm going to give a huge thank
you to clorox for sponsoring this part
of the video before heading out to work
and starting my day
and leaving bear unattended i want to
make sure i leave my house really clean
so i'm going to show you how i clean my
commonly touched surfaces like this
countertop right here using
clorox bleach with cloromax i actually
pre-mixed the solution as directed right
there i have my gloves to keep me safe
i dip my white rag and i wipe it down
wipe it down now in all seriousness
you're gonna get proven disinfection
you're gonna kill 99.9
percent of germs with only a third of a
cup just make sure you follow directions
really carefully on that one you could
use this on a lot of high-touch
areas remember i told you those are the
areas bear
you're distracting me buddy those are
the areas that are going to have the
most germs on them so you think faucets
doorknobs just a lot of non-porous
surfaces that get touched quite
frequently and as they say when it
really matters
trust clorox let's give clorox a huge
thank you for sponsoring this portion of
the video
i'm about to hop in the shower clean
myself and get ready
to take on another day at the hospital
it was a very crazy start to the morning
i was woken up several times throughout
the night by
news agencies reaching out asking if i'm
able to do television this morning i'm
actually going into the office so i
won't be able to do media today
is an outpatient family medicine day
tgif
don are you ready i am ready what are we
doing we're giving you your flu shot
why keep you healthy are you gonna be
really rough with the needle
i'm gonna be so gentle i think i might
jab you a little bit she's gonna judge
me but that's because
you know i missed my hair this is the
flu shot we're gonna close the door
because it's getting serious
be rough with me let's go pull it up as
hard as you need to it's stretchy
i want you to relax and relax one two
three
huge
perfect that was really good that was
you did not even move that was smooth
while we're sitting here i have my bone
pen but in all seriousness
everyone at home please get your flu
shot we really need it now more than
ever it's covered 19 season and while
this flu shot does not prevent you from
getting covered 19 it does prevent you
from getting a virus which may look like
covet 19 which will lead to a ton of
confusion
on top of that with hospitals being busy
handling cova 19 patients we don't
want you to get sick with the flu and
then have to come into the hospital for
care it's funny i'm actually in an exam
room right now
but as you can tell there's no patient
here but there is a computer
and this computer has a webcam and a
microphone all set up for virtual
patient visits which we've been doing a
lot of
in fact telemedicine has absolutely
blown up during the covet 19 pandemic
and rightfully so
a lot of things you can take care by a
virtual visit having a conversation
about medications perhaps looking at
some rashes there's all sorts of
guidance that we can give through a
virtual visit
that being said a virtual visit does not
replace a visit face-to-face with your
doctor there's all sorts of benefits to
seeing a doctor
in person including getting an accurate
physical exam reading body cues
having a better doctor patient
connection the physical exam is probably
the most important though that's you
yeah you know what time it is what time
is it
it's lunch time i'm treating today we're
chilling with a favorite dr mike here
what do you want to eat you always tell
me i don't order enough food where's the
bubble keeping on the order
team what are we eating place down on
main street
okay sandwiches yeah and greg any votes
ah not really
tell me how cold it has affected your
life it has affected me
i would say personally okay and
um emotionally at the end of it if we
work really hard to stay safe
and follow guidelines we'll be
better off in the long run and that's
something that gets me by
i want to show you guys real quick some
code related changes in the office
this is our waiting area social
distancing is important we're also
not having patients wait here they
actually call us from the parking lot
let us know that they're here we get
them checked in
meet them right by the door do a
temperature check ask a few questions
bring them in following a one-way path
patients can only walk through this
hallway
exit through there enter through there
this is cool i like pointing like this
stacy why are you laughing
just stop laughing at me for one second
how do you feel about five million
people seeing you it's a very trying
experience
so i just had a really interesting
patient encounter with a young gentleman
who's complaining of
easy bruising and actually bruising that
happened over the last weekend without
any trauma or any
inciting incident and in these
conditions a lot of people start going
to clotting issues
platelet dysfunction even cancer
sometimes what's interesting with this
patient all those things have already
been ruled out because they were seen by
hematologists who was a blood specialist
this is the second time they're being
evaluated for this
approximately a year later and right
away my mind jumped to something that
was actually learned in medical school
and that's ehlers-danlos syndrome which
is a connective tissue disorder
that causes hypermobile joints skin
issues like
easy bruising so i asked the patient if
he has any hypermobility and he said oh
yeah consider myself double jointed he's
able to bring his
thumb all the way to his wrist the skin
is very elastic very loose so now we're
beginning the
the evaluation to see if he has eds but
unless we think outside of the box when
a patient comes in you can miss a
diagnosis like eds that's why it's
important to get a thorough thorough
history each time you talk to a patient
i swear sometimes like you think people
are doing work
you think they're doing work but instead
here's what they're doing
here's what they're doing what is that
that's not work
you're looking at dog pictures what are
you oh abuse
call hr without my breaking news they
put you in a tutu
that is my tues i did that for breast
cancer and it is breast cancer awareness
month so folks if you're of age get
screened talk to your doctor about it
today was
sort of a short day it's only about five
six o'clock i thought i'd decide to
drive over to the main hospital
and show you what we're doing here in
terms of preparing for a potential
second wave of covenant yo look who i
run into
who is that who is this
okay
now this ladies and gentlemen is a sign
i can get behind the stairs
of the hospital this is where we got all
our exercise in when we were residents
this is where i would sprint up and down
when there was a code blue you know
chest compression stress compression
chest compression
all right we're officially on the floor
that can be used
if there is a need for overflow of icu
patients specifically made
to battle coven 19. a lot of people have
been wondering what are hospitals doing
to prepare
if there is a second wave of cloven 19.
well this is what we're doing there's
technological advancements
i'm going to show you throughout this
unit that is a prime example of
collaboration between the nursing staff
the healthcare staff engineering staff
which you may not think is part of the
healthcare team
but they're a vital part of the
healthcare team engineering basically
made these eight-bed pods for us
and they gave us a monitor system so we
can look inside all the rooms so we
don't have to go in the room and also
they gave us these monitors so that we
can adjust
the physiologic monitors in the room so
we don't have to go in
the other thing they did is um during
cobit when
nurses needed something they had to bang
on the door to get someone's attention
and scream through the door saying i
need this so
intercom system wow so all the rooms had
intercom systems
on the med surg units the uh doors
had little slits for windows yep um so
here they made the windows much bigger
easy visibility and we don't have to
peer through a little slip the other
thing is outlet oh yeah
something that we take for granted we
don't even think about them outlets on
the wall
in the hallway why why should they be in
the hallway because that's all the
equipment is
right so you don't want to have it
inside the patient's room because then
if you need to change it that's a waste
of ppe that's a potential exposure the
other great thing that
engineering did listen to us is they
built these little holes in the wall
what that does is we feed our iv
tubing through it each of the rooms is
absolutely what we call a scrubber
so it can make any room into negative
pressure
look at that all these patients have
negative pressure exactly so for those
of you who don't know what negative
pressure
room is it basically sucks the air into
the room keeps the air into the room so
that infection doesn't potentially seek
out into the environment
getting other sick which protects other
patients and nursing staff doctors cmas
everyone who's around so
how many total beds are available on
this floor
so there's going to be a total of 32. 32
beds
and they're available ready to use
already if we need them correct so we're
prepared for the surge we're ready to
help people out
and these can be full on icus it can be
full on ics wow okay so
we're ready is there like a central
nursing station can we see that we have
a large
um monitoring screen here the cameras
that we can look at all the rooms right
here and then our central monitoring
station is right here and then you have
oxygen meters
medical air the vacuums everything is
set up so it could be done right here
without
necessarily entering the patient's room
correct hopefully we won't need to use
this unit much but if the situation
arises
we can absolutely know that we're going
to be taken care of our patients are
going to be taken care of
our staff is going to be safe do you
have any party words for our youtube
audience here
no just um you know don't delay care if
you're sick
come to the hospital we are a safe place
to be we have many lessons that we
learned
that we've put into place already and
we're here for you healthcare hero right
here
all righty you guys got the full tour
the covet
wing i am on my way home not to relax
but to do some notes every job has its
pros and cons
writing long notes cons of this job but
the pros most
definitely outweigh it i'd never trade
my career for anything else
[Music]
you